oh look at this this is a good one some
suggest that parker's powers include the
male spider's ability to hypnotize
females stop come on yes my spider lord
all right so cut us off what's been the
best thing about spider-man and what's
been the worst thing about being
spider-man i think one of the best
things about spider-man it was me and
you guys
oh you know
um and i can't really think of the worst
thing i think the worst thing about
playing spider-man is the
lack of
toilet breaks i get um because the suit
is so tight right and we all know how
long it takes me to take it on and off
right and i don't get to go to the
toilet all that often so that's probably
the worst thing but the best thing is
meeting you guys
and we're here in london and london's
not ready we're going out for dinner
tonight and london better buckle up
[Laughter]
i'm next both the spider-man movies and
euphoria are in high school settings
what advice do you think roo and mj
would give each other i don't know if
roo should be given any advice right now
i think maybe she should just
chill you know
um use some advice maybe maybe ask her
in a few years you know nice she'll have
great advice then
but um i would say i don't know i don't
know if they would give each other
advice so much just i i think they'd
actually really get along i think they
would i think they would be good for
each other i think mj would be excellent
for roo yeah
yeah they'd be great friends okay ned
has done such a great job keeping peter
secret and you have done a great job
keeping spider-man no way home a secret
so are you naturally talented at secret
keeping
you know honestly i think that i don't
want to lose my job so i think if
anything i'm good at like not wanting to
ruin my career
but uh fair enough
but not the best at keeping secrets on
set
this is a multi
question question i think uh i think
everyone's pretty good um
and i think it's mostly because no one
really knows what happens so
sometimes you don't know you can't yeah
you can't say anything so it's pretty
everything's pretty secretive and who's
the worst
is that even a question yeah
is it me you've been doing so well
though yeah you've this this whole time
for this one has been released i've
already dropped my best on this those
calls here and there but overall really
good that's why they've paid me with
youtube
we don't trust him a lot yeah it's tough
i'm not your team all right if you could
meet another version of yourself that
exists in the multiverse who would that
be and what would you hope they would be
like
hmm
if i could meet myself i would like to
meet the version of myself
that has just won the ballon d'or
thomas thomas is the greatest football
player who've ever lived
that is the version of myself i would
like to meet
and i would then like to kill him
and take all of his power and become an
absorbent
and absorb him
oh
yeah that's it that's who i would like
to meet who would you like to meet well
it's just a question for you no it's
just tommy tom and really yeah oh i
didn't know that would you like to meet
more version of yourself um
[Music]
i don't know
um i would like to meet a version of
myself
that
um maybe became a teacher like my
parents yeah
i think it'd be really funny to meet the
version of sunday they're like drinks
and smokes
yeah right
a party animal a party i don't know
maybe maybe they're out there
definitely out there yeah
i'm not funny
i'd be so worried like what have you
done as a damn
this isn't you
okay which other mcu hero or villain
could really use ned leeds as a best
friend
who i i think that everyone kind of
needs a net leads
and not to just want to be in everyone's
movies but i think that yeah i think
that everyone sort of needs a best
friend a guy in the chair for sure uh i
can't really say one specifically
because i feel like they're all pretty
much
not damaged but like they're all pretty
much like in hard places
what um what like non-mcu movie do you
think ned lee's would fit in
ah i'd love to see ned lee's in like a
saw movie
[Laughter]
yeah that would be that'd be really
funny yeah any anything crazy horror or
crazy dramatic
in a horror movie
but yeah so any any of the any of the
heroes who who would love to have him
around for sure
name your top three spider-man villains
you've had to square off against and who
do you want to see him take on next
that's tricky
i think the vulture's got to be in there
because he's my first
that one's cool i think jake's got to be
in there because he's my love
he's jake
and i think willem
the fight scenes that we have with
william and this is almost so crazy and
so scary that it really was
awesome to like explore different kind
of spider-man action
who do you want to see him take on this
though next
you know what i actually think that
morbius film looks really cool
and it's more scary that film yeah it
does look sorry i think morbius could be
quite a cool thing too yeah to mix that
up spider-man versus a vampire yeah
[Laughter]
like that
all right like that
what was the most heartwarming scene in
all of the franchise for you
the most heartwarming scene
i know um
we all know oh yeah for sure
[Music]
are you really thinking about this well
no i'm trying to think i'm trying to
think of a scene that i can talk about
you know i can't there's a scene in this
film that is amazing between the three
of us which we can't talk about because
it's a spoiler but i think you in
avengers end game when we just oh yeah
that is really sweet it's a really
special moment like really grounds that
film i think it's a moment where people
really
sometimes with these big action films
you forget that they're supposed to
exist in a realistic universe
seeing you at school and that it's
affected kids really makes that film
feel very grounded
i would agree
all right yeah oh it's my sin what was
the funniest spider-man scene to shoot
i i can't say
nothing
um you can't say that i can't say and um
so it was some of my best work
personally
off camera unfortunately i was on a roll
i was making everybody laugh that day
for sure the poor sound man that you're
coming in i will say that and i and i
added that into my number one joke yeah
well done right
zendaya's low-key funny as hell yeah
what can i say
all right is it my turn it is yeah okay
what is one of your most favorite
spider-man scenes in any other film or
tv show
[Music]
hmm
in any of the previous films
yeah
put my ring on
my favorite spider-man moment i feel bad
like choosing one of my own
yeah yeah they said
they said other
so not yours so it can't be yours
oh my god your brain was just like well
mine yeah obviously there's moments
i really like toby's fight scene with
doc on the side of the building
that's really cool there's a great
moment where doc throws the
the hands of the clock down and like
webs it and then like flings it back at
him i think that's really cool
what memory will you take away from the
three of us working together
[Music]
um
i'm trying to think yeah that does a lot
all of it yeah i don't know what i'm
trying to think i will say though like
now this movie has some great memories
but i will say the first movie
yeah sticks with me the most what
they're always about a picnic yeah we
all went on a picnic we had like a whole
adventure like a whole like class
adventure yeah or remember the the
decathlon thing yeah yeah how funny like
i don't like how like we used to say to
each other like come over on the weekend
and we can all play in my pool and we
did yeah we literally did all the
playing in the pool we did movie nights
all the time movie nights was a big one
we had a lot of fun the cinema club was
a big one i think the party that we had
at my house on the last day of shooting
was a big one yeah
i have a great video of me and you
dancing i know you have the video yes i
mean you don't have a sexual
yeah it's great classic yeah very sweet
yeah
that's the last one i've got what do you
have i have
a couple more
i have two more for jacob
okay
what was the best action-packed scene in
our spider-man trilogy
oh i can't speak on that can i yeah
that's tough um previous movies uh yeah
previous movies i think
um i think in the second one we all sort
of like
had to run away from explosions and
stuff and yeah and like i still have a
dent in my house yeah from running away
from like yes from the venice when you
got your legs stuck in there oh my
goodness you really do actually
still there get that checked out
broken so yeah i guess anything from the
second movie and again the third one is
filled with so many things that we can't
even speak on that it'll probably trump
all those other things but for sure like
all those other although i also think
like
like
my one of my favorite scenes is like we
were they were talking about the other
day but the um
you guys in the car finding out that
the vulture thing
oh yeah oh yeah i love that scene i know
that no action is happening but it's
like so it's like potential action it's
great yeah it's intense for sure yeah
and when like when laura's like oh look
at this picture you're like yeah it's so
cute
it cracks me up every time stress so how
was it like to work with benedict
cumberbatch
it was pretty amazing you know i've
worked with ben quite a few times right
on the avengers movies
um
and he's awesome yeah stranger's a great
character benedict is a great guy uh he
stole my bean bag though this movie that
you're working on also deals with
electricity
all the correlation bitter subject
um but yeah benedict stole my bean bag
he actually him and i actually supposed
to go were supposed to go surfing a few
weeks ago
yeah but i was not able to go i have a
great picture of him skateboarding
around the world you do yeah which is
cool because it's like doctor strange
classic
if ned got a spin-off what do you think
it would look like
pitch us your show oh yeah
so a ned lead spin-off would probably be
uh one where he
works with
the avengers shield shield yes yes
so right like an official guy in the
chair so he would be sick and i feel
like he'd probably work with every
superhero
um not just spiderman and leave me i
mean i would i would give you all my
time and also other people my time nice
and i feel like give me all of your time
giving other people time and i think
that would be a great series on disney
plus
[Laughter]
a tv show with you and
fury yeah really funny i think that'll
be hilarious is like his new little uh
why did you make that decision
yeah because the other one is a spoiler
yeah
interesting his other possible plot oh
teachers of midtown though for real
teachers
they're
what a great show that would be just
like the mundane activities of like
being a teacher in midtown
and then like in the news something
happens with superheroes
reacting to
it thanks vandango yeah thank you
fandango
you